good morning dean miller
colleagues on the platform
friends parents
other relatives
and of course members of the class of
2017.
it's an honor as yale's new president to
say these words
which i know you and your parents
your families and your friends have
waited quite some time to hear
welcome to yale
i have something in common with you
today because i too
am a freshman
although i've been on campus for more
than three decades this is in fact my
first freshman address
as the president of this inspiring
university
like you i'm feeling a little bit
nervous a bit humble
certainly excited
like you i also spent too much time this
week
speaking
and not sleeping and now find myself
with laryngitis so
perhaps that fits some of you too
i know
that like you
our parents are feeling quite proud of
us today
you know as the saying goes
behind every new galley
is a stunned parent
each of you arrived at yale with your
own story and i look forward to hearing
them
this morning though i'd like to begin by
telling you the story
of my father
it's a story that many americans share
and that i know
many of you share
in fact we actually sing about it just a
few moments ago in the beautiful hymn
written by a member of the yale class of
1820
oh god beneath thy guiding hand our
exiled fathers crossed the sea
laws freedom truth and faith came with
those exiles or the waves that's what we
just sang
now my father's parents my grandparents
they came to the united states by way of
warsaw
and jerusalem
they actually first met each other on a
ship across the atlantic
in the midst of their journey between
their old and their new worlds
together they lived on the lower east
side of new york
spent a little time in chicago and ended
up in the bronx
where my father was raised
like many immigrants my grandparents
were poor in means
but rich in culture and spirit
my grandmother worked as a bookkeeper
and after my grandfather lost his small
store during the depression
he took care of the elderly and the
infirm
but today i stand before you a professor
of psychology
and president of one of the world's
finest universities no
the finest university
today i stand before you humbled
because i know
that there are very few places in the
world where in two generations a family
can rise from modest means
to this kind of role in life
how did it happen
the answer to that question in my family
i am sure resembles the answer in many
of yours
growing up in a small apartment in the
bronx my grandparents encouraged my
father to take education seriously
as with at least two of you here this
morning
he attended the bronx high school of
science
a fantastic public school
and then city college of new york and
brooklyn college
ultimately he received a doctorate in
chemistry from harvard
well nobody's perfect
all of this education
all of it
was without financial cost
to my father's family
in a country where opportunity was
within reach for both the rich and the
poor my grandparents values launched my
father toward a career as a polymer
chemist at bell labs and later as a
professor at the university of southern
california
and this education allowed my own
childhood to be decidedly middle class
and free for the most part from
financial worry
my father's personal dream to be a
scientist
regardless of how or where he grew up
this is the american dream as well
study hard
work hard and you will be rewarded by
social and economic mobility
because of education
the latter of opportunity was it was
within reach for my father
of course this dream is not unique to
america
those of you who come to yale from
overseas about 10
of your class
may have experienced a version of the
american dream in your own country
and in your own family
from the bronx
to budapest from san diego to seoul
there is a common understanding that
transcends borders of the power of
education
in fact on a recent trip to asia i heard
the phrase chinese dream many times
and it signified in part the very idea
i'm talking about now
for the purposes of these remarks though
i'll use the phrase american dream
and this morning
i worry
about whether the american dream is
still possible
and whether education
is still the best ticket
to socioeconomic mobility
is it still as the historian who made
popular the idea of the american dream
wrote in 1931 is it still
a dream of a land in which life
should be better and richer and fuller
for everyone with opportunity for each
according to ability or achievement
a dream of being able to grow to fullest
development as man and woman
unhampered
by the barriers which had slowly been
erected in the older civilizations
unrepressed by social orders which had
developed for the benefit of classes
rather than for the simple human being
of any and every class
higher education has been viewed in
american history as the vehicle
by which to pursue this dream
and to improve one's personal
circumstances
as it was with my first gen father
but it is an idea as old as america
itself
for as thomas jefferson wrote
if the condition of man is to be
progressively ameliorated
as we fondly hope and believe
education is to be the tree chief
instrument in affecting it
that is why even after writing the
declaration of independence
after serving as america's first
secretary of state
second vice president and third
president
jefferson would later say that founding
the university of virginia was the
accomplishment about which he felt the
most pride
this same vision this same emphasis on
education
has motivated progressive legislation
from the moral acts which created the
land grant colleges to the gi bill
to title iv and the federal pell grant
program
these investments are worth making
because college graduates develop broad
and deep knowledge
sharp critical thinking and
communication skills
and the ability to work collaboratively
and as a result they are three times as
likely as those without a degree
to move from the lowest levels of family
income to the top level
though the american dream is deeply
rooted in our history
it is not a guarantee
it is something that must be project
protected
and preserved
and passed on with care
to the next generation
and yet
in recent years
this dream has been tested
college completion has increased
but only among families in the top half
of the income distribution and not among
the bottom half
another threat to the american dream
was revealed by the economists carolyn
hoxby and christopher avery
they found that many high achieving
students from less well-off families do
not even apply to the very best colleges
and universities especially if they are
from smaller more rural parts of the
country
these students do not know anyone who
has attended a place like yale and they
do not think a place like yale
is for them
their families do not know that
need-based financial aid is available
and that they would contribute far less
than the sticker price of many other
colleges and universities of many of the
colleges and universities in this
country
why did i choose to talk about yale
and the american dream today
to assure you especially those of you
from families that are not affluent
that the agree that the dream
is very much alive and well
here at yale
10 years after they graduated members of
the yale class of 1998
reported impressive and similar
average salaries and
a higher level of life satisfaction
regardless of whether they came from
families whose standard of living was
far below average
below average
average
or above average
yale has seen its has seen socioeconomic
mobility as a central pillar of its
mission since its earliest days
the eminent yale historian george w
pearson
a man whose love for yale and her
history
garnered him the honorary title father
yale
wrote
half the boys in each colonial class
were from families of no social standing
in the 19th century yell continued to
attract and to care for many of the most
modest means
and tuition
was religiously kept low
by eighteen fifty
it was just thirty nine dollars
sorry parents
a yale student named david avery noted
in 1768
there appears to be a laudable ambition
to excel in knowledge
it is not he that has got the finest
coat or largest ruffles that is esteemed
here at present
the students may expect marks of
distinction to be put upon the best
scholars and speakers
now let me pause here and note
that we should all be relieved that
having the largest ruffles is no longer
a sign of superiority
i say say that a little self-consciously
though
i raised the issue of social mobility
because if you have any doubt
that the american dream still lives on
today
if you like me
wonder
whether someone like my father
could fulfill his dreams
just look around you
look at yourselves
look at the students next to you
they have different talents and ideas
from you
different family backgrounds from you
but each of you have worked incredibly
hard
to make it here if you have any doubt
that the american dream lives on
gays class of 2017 gaze into the eyes of
your parents
they know
looking back at you here today
that the unthinkable
is still possible
but let me mention something that is
just a bit more difficult to discuss
you class of 2017
bring your different cultures different
religions different ethnicities
different sexual orientations to this
campus
and as any yale student will tell you
one of yale's most inspiring qualities
is that yalies are quite comfortable
discussing these differences
but you are also
an economically diverse group
some of you hail from families of
limited means
and others
from great abundance
most of you are from families somewhere
in between
and yet
these differences remain just below the
surface
roommates become aware of these
disparities of course
but they are uncomfortable talking about
them
and sharing
what their lives were like prior to
attending yale
i believe that talking about
socioeconomic status is one of the last
taboos among yale students
when the issue of money comes up
students are often
profoundly uncomfortable
this is understandable
yell
is such a great equalizer most of the
time
that when it comes to money people may
feel guilty if they think they have more
than someone else
or embarrassed if they have less
some of you will hold a work study job
others will not
some of you will be able to travel
overseas during spring break
others not
some of you can afford to accept unpaid
internships in the summer others of you
cannot
when you decide to purchase a sofa for
your common room or make plans to eat in
one of new haven's wonderful restaurants
some of your roommates will not think
twice about doing so
but for others it will be a financial
stretch
perhaps too large a one
yell has taken many measures to try to
find ways to equalize the college
experience
gone are the days when students spent
many many hours waiting tables or going
hungry
still
differences exist
and it makes little sense to pretend
they do not
and little sense to think yale can
obliterate all distinctions or make
everything possible for those who do not
have as much as others
to the class of 2017 i encourage you
to be sensitive
and open to one another
you will meet students here from all
walks of life
the uncomfortable conversations that you
will certainly have in commons or in
your common room
represent opportunities for true
understanding and true friendship
with classmates whose families may be
far different
from your own
one of our college masters told me about
two students in his college
one
felt
so guilty about his family's wealth that
he refused ever to invite any friends
home
and his parents complained about this to
the master
in that same college another student now
graduated was ashamed that she had grown
up in a tin shack
and she hid this from all of her friends
at the end of her time at yale her
friend's friend found out the truth
about her background
she was stunned and relieved to know
that instead of thinking less of her
they thought more of her for triumphing
triumphing over challenging
circumstances
this is what yellies are like
although after all there are hard
aspects of life
but they could be made less difficult
however by the openness and sharing for
which yale students are generally
so well known
yale students pearson wrote are not
loners
not solitary
they are part of each other
as a product of the american dream
myself
i am inspired by it
i am committed to preserving it
and while admitting that it has been
idealized historically and perhaps
compromised in contemporary society i am
convinced that yours can be the
generation
that ensures
it is kept alive and i mean that whether
you come from pittsburgh or pretoria or
ponce
i am thankful that yale's financial aid
policies and practices sustain and
propel this promise
and allow so many of you access
to the american dream
but more than that
i am thankful that a yale education
helps to develop the habits of mind and
behavior
that will first lead you to
uncomfortable and challenging
conversations
but then motivate you
to make constructive contributions to
your professions
and to your families
to your countries
and to the world
yours can be
the generation that helps to develop a
more complex vision of the american
dream one that both moves beyond social
mobility and also includes living a life
of growth
of meaning
of significance
affordable education and opportunities
for fulfilling work
are essential for this vision
it is my hope
indeed it is my conviction
that you will continue to ensure
that the dream of a better life
will be
woven permanently
into the fabric of our societies
around the world
so however it is that you arrived here
at yale
on behalf
of all of my colleagues on the platform
this morning
welcome parents
welcome families
welcome
class
of 2017.